germany's next topmodel folge 2
die wird jetzt sein im fernsehen
ausgestrahlt und treibt mir das
natürlich mal wieder von vorne bis
hinten angeguckt
die gestrige folge sind hier im revue
passieren lassen ganz kurz noch ebene
hinweis hier ist übrigens nichts wieder
von mir irgendwie beleidigend gemeint
weil er damen und herren und kandidaten
innen bitte nicht wieder mich schreiben
und jetzt geh mit meiner instagram story
das sind alles flaschen hier ja ich bin
direkt und richtig positiver energie da
rein gestartet und dann kamen natürlich
direkt das ist halt auch so eine sache
die ich mich immer frage woher nehmen
die diese 150000 euro von 150000 euro
krieg so 150000 cheeseburger das recht
locker eine woche bei sandra ich weiß
nicht wie es euch geht aber das läuft ja
seit 20 minuten wenn man bei jedem mal
wo selbstbewusst gesagt wurde und
trinken müssen dann wäre ich jetzt tot
und kraftlos neben der city das motto
schlechthin der diesjährigen staffel den
ich aber gute und vor allem fand ich es
auch richtig gut als heidi dann sagt der
fürs selbstbewusstsein training heute
haben wir den profis schlechthin dabei
mich heidi klum hat der erste brief der
erste brief nach nach nach zehn minuten
gab es den ersten brief
doch nicht so ganz verstehe ist die
haben jetzt ihr catwalk training im flur
gemacht wo soll denn das shooting
stattfindet auf den club dass wahrheit
die nächste sache wo ich mir einfach nur
so dachte hey wer hat sich das
ausgedacht so die haben halt ihre bude
da bezogen und catwalk training im flur
ich hier ich hab's gefilmt
das hat sich irgendwie alles mehr wie
big brother angefühlt so dass diese die
ganze zeit beobachtet werden in ihrem
haus lagerhallen ähnlichen dings aber
dann kam natürlich selbst wahrscheinlich
das nächste bis das heißt wir haben den
nächsten brief wir haben schon wieder
die nächsten brief und dran und gezeigt
wie die das schlafen die pendler mit 20
leuten in einem raum guckt euch das mal
an waren die nicht sonst immer in
irgendwelchen fetten villen in los
angeles oder so gut
vielleicht ist auch gerade irgend so
eine krankheit da die halt so umgeht
doch dann wurden die mädels geweckt und
das nicht irgendwie mit einem ganz
normalen wecker nähe seht einfach selbst
[Musik]
die werden sofort das ist auch mein
bäcker jeden morgen party mal die haben
im moment das sind 25 mädels und die
haben zwei badezimmer 25 mädels teilen
sich dort bei germany's next topmodel
falls jemand von euch irgendwie das ist
die nächste sache die wir eigentlich auf
unser gntm bingo schreiben können meine
lieben freunde jemand verliert einen
schuh auf den laufsteg
jetzt muss auch schonmal in dubai marina
und auf der pariser fashion week
passiert ich habe natürlich gekonnt oder
spielt ich dachte wenn alles vegetarier
doch mal auf wird dieser werbung und
dann auch immer gleich gehts weiter ein
scheiß als dort die gestrige folge gntm
bestand wirklich zu 99 prozent aus
werbung und ein bisschen jeans team so
drauf geprügelt so mehr nicht und
während der werbung
jetzt geht es weiter mit tee und
präsentiert von volvo amazon coca cola
apple und krieg
[Musik]
und dieser rooney leute standen 21 28
nationen grabungs tanzen heide wo sind
deine augen raum wo sind deine
augenbrauen
wo sind deine augenbrauen sich aus dem
gebiet das ist eins zu eins da gebiet
eins zu eins ich war einfach drinnen
plötzlich habe richtig mitgefiebert ich
kann euch jetzt schon sagen was ich
denke was meine tipps dem fürs finale
alex
und von der einen habe ich den namen
vergessen aber das war die aus syrien
kommt unfassbar der wiehre rose zerstört
direkt nach einer stunde show oder so
genoss sie war übrigens auch am start an
war natürlich wieder werbepause die habe
ich fürs zähneputzen genutzt
[Musik]
die sparraten zähneputzen und jetzt ist
hier wieder werbung oder war es mit euch
die 150000 euro danach email brücke hier
doch sie geht einfach als das was ich
von jedem mädchen kassiere die seit
bereits corp gegangen verlust sich genau
das was ich mir das schon vorgestern
aufgegeben nein bleibt wissen
motivation
ich hab mich meine tage mann ich will
die top-bonität der werbung es war die
zehntausendste werbung ca
es wird irgendwann in der zukunft zu
sein dass der fernseher erkennt welche
personen welcher altersgruppe mit
welchen interessen dz reformen
bildschirm gerade sitzen und
dementsprechend einwerbung anpasst und
ausstrahlt also beispielsweise ich wenn
ich den themen fernsehen gucke jetzt
eher werbung bekommen für irgendwie weil
ich fußball sachen technik keine ahnung
was und niemand anderes zum beispiel
zwölfjähriges mädchen eher für call of
duty oder so beispielsweise wenn nicht
so interessant mal zu wissen dann ganz
aber auch sie hier
die hat er irgendwann halben astronauten
helm auf das ist ja die designerin der
episode und dann höre ich ein bisschen
genauer angeguckt und anscheinend habe
ich schon mal was mit ihr zu tun denn
ich war mal mit sandra am nürburgring
bei einer chance von ihr doch leider
kamen sondern und ich irgendwie drei
stunden zu spät und haben nur noch die
aftershow mitgenommen und das habe ich
dann von einer freundin noch mal
bestätigt bekommen
aber dann heidi mir sogar noch ein
kompliment gemacht
danke danke
1940 im radio
wie ist raus
die kandidaten von der heidi mehr
selbstbewusstsein beim danson gefordert
hat obwohl sie nicht richtig hören kann
ist einfach raus geflogen
die war mit einer meiner favoriten und
erzähle ich das heutige video zauber
endet meine lieben freunde wenn euch mal
wieder meine reaction auf meine eigene
reaction ob von instagram auf die mtm
gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen
unter dem video abonniert nur ein
kanalfest auch keinen usaid und dieser
extrem gemütliche rudi also der ist
wirklich ich würde ein bentley von einer
klippe schmeißen und viel lieber in
diesem rudi rumlaufen 21 12 25 15